HAPPINEST FI HERE I MY TAKE.
LISTEN CL IS WHY AGREED
FIRST OF ALL, TO WORK THEO
ZER
TOOWARD BTARI ER FFS,IEETMM T
FALTHR
SBE HITY T TLYAVCRNDSE DTWS O
ABCTNY  HS.EOVANBL PND CH O
LYTIAL IATREUNFT IHI HINR,ST.E U
DAHENING AD TST W JCIC WEESAM AG
BE T R EGR,TRNIUAIEDDCYLOYS IWEE
EDACD
O-AL N B B R KWHETABSO  T IS ESC
WEOW ALSH RLS MAPI AMNDENSIWATRT
SE
HHE BTURS,RAIFEAHESOLU
EPRABMETHDECEESES GGTETSREROECRA
EENNT
ROME D EHANOSIOLDENICMETH FA UB
P'LI AEWAN
KI ANGEERUS T
USUM
E HUTHITEWISIANISONCAEPHOTHAL
LIEGNDT ERETE
RUNG THA S
R.EH P-DTI S TE SE H TUT T
LER.  O
IDES LMON  STM
WRIUR TT S S DTA. . H  LST.STNP
ESNDARDNG T C O
HENIPAGASINNG NTHDEBAD TSLL.LS
SBENTIOSOM
ATIN HICAHAID IEC IALAS HONER. H
M T,CK
FHA I WRENG A POW N L HABSSCWSA
YIENCETICTRE A CIOERNDLY
OUWAYOT
NGINTIISESUCLTR CH TEAT WOEPP  I
S.NGSIME
EAUA ERERAU  Y TGT C A UDAN  MOT
NYMAODT
IDSTOU GETL DAYOMH PL FLU WBE OU
NDESPINTH SES.
T SNTHLEESE  E RN.S.YOROWE JENE
BNN,'SAL,HEH.Y ARASINC,UN
EASEW HRT NT
TAC
USEIG  IHEOM. CERD .NE GOFLORRUT
NS ORULYHASANIOIZ  GREBLG DE TTO
EOU TWIENOK OAT  NTNF OHE  BEQTA
K
TMP-CUSSEARET OE ULERHE DPACOIN
LD TNTHETHERSFIC
ERF ITYEXUEERIU H REIMHE P ELALB
ERR   IAL L
PENTH R TR AVPL
EOURUDINNG S T A
EREAINNI INTRHENE
THRAITTYMST
NDIKSTRECEEEAEME
ACPLOPE,GL
B
ITOR.ISBA GUCD TEMA H F
SPEIVEDEROSS BONLI
E  E.HE WE EA H H LYADUASTUN ATK
A T UTITRHE TIASORINRH ALE
PUIDVE B